All right. So, you built an agent, you
launched it, everything works pretty
well in a demo, everyone is happy. But
now let me ask you a few simple
questions. So, how do you know if it's
actually working out there? How do you
watch across hundreds or thousands of
real conversations every day? How do you
feel or understand the health of the
system? How do you make it better? How
do you find the holes that you don't
know are there yet? And that's the
thing, right? So, most of the talks
about the agents end up the moment when
you ship. So, apparently it did work,
the end.
But I think the shipping is the moment
when the real work begins. And somehow
only a few people are talking about
that. And I'm calling it the missing
layer. So, let's dive into it.
So, that's the world that we're living.
So, you can create the whole product,
you can create a whole startup in a
couple of days, in a couple of weeks.
You can write 100,000 of lines of code.
You can spend a lot of tokens.
And to be honest, it is the easiest part
today with the help of the latest
models.
But I think the shipping is the moment
when the real work begins. Because you
need to close the loop as soon as
possible. So, after you launch, you need
to have some control and understanding
of the system. And uh from my
experience, the loop is uh at least as
important as the product itself,
sometimes even more. Because the tight
feedback is the one that helps you to
make product better every single day.
And that's the missing layer, and that's
what the rest of this talk is all about.
So, what happens after you launch? And
this is not something surprising. We had
the same questions in the classical old
software. You need to monitor what is
happening, you need to understand how it
behaves, you need to have some logs to
detect the problems and fix them.
Uh and for agentic systems, each one of
those are even harder, and sometimes
uh they turn into something genuinely
new.
So, let's talk about why this is hard
and why this is hard now.
So, the agent is not a normal software,
right? You You don't have a few features
and several buttons. You don't have a
predefined flow that you can test before
you go to the to the live.
Uh and the coverage is endless. So,
think about like cloud code or codex,
they can do a giant range of stuff
whatever user needs and most of the
agents do the same, right? So, you give
the instructions and they can handle it.
And you cannot write all the
conversations
in advance.
So, this leads to a detailed part of the
problem. The part that keeps me up all
night.
Which is you lose the feel for your own
system. So, after you
build the product, you need to have some
kind of understanding, does it get
better or worse? So, we need to monitor
and understand what is happening.
And the problem is that the normal the
normal safety nets don't save you here.
Uh and believe me, we tried
a few stuff. We we we build the unit
test. We had some regex, some rule-based
checks. We even created some scripts to
simulate the customer conversation.
Uh
and yeah, it helps in some ways.
but at the end of the day,
it is like only one slice of the whole
problem.
Because
customers always do something different.
Uh you cannot write it all down. They
are too many and they are all different.
And Harrison for it in the same way. So,
you don't know what your agent will do
until it is in the production.
So, why this is a new problem? So, as
you know, LLMs are not
deterministic.
The same input can have a different
path. Even slight modification of the
input can cause a different trajectory
and the coverage is endless. You cannot
list it all down. You cannot pretest
until you go in the production.
The second and the scariest one is the
failure height itself. So, let's think
about what happens when the agent is
running for a long time. It struggled in
the middle of a task. Uh it has some
problems but it was lucky.
Uh it was recovered. It finds some
workarounds.
Uh try some other tool calls or
whatever. And you don't get any red
alerts, any problems on a dashboard.
Everything looks fine. But you know,
this is a early warning for you. This is
a problem that uh that is hidden uh and
that lives in your code base. And uh you
need to fix it as soon as possible
because if you're talking about uh
reliable agents, uh it shouldn't be
depend on the luck, right?
And uh
also as an Anthropic mentioned in the
blog post, sometimes the agent love to
make marketing features as complete
uh without checking they actually
worked.
The next one is uh the tool calling,
right? So, the tool surface is a huge.
So, long-running task needs a hundred of
tools and thousands of tools. Um
sometimes it have a uh several
summarization in the middle. It use some
sub agent, writes a lot of code. It use
a terminal for sure. It calls some other
company services, third-party libraries.
And uh
they they work pretty different way uh
all the time. So, actually you don't
know what you're looking for.
So, sometimes finish doesn't mean it is
helpful for the user. Maybe there was
any there wasn't any problem. So, agent
finished, everything looks good. The
answer was successful.
But what happens like for example for
our use case, sometimes uh user asked to
build the itinerary. Agent run the flow.
It built the trip. But it took a
different service. It made a lot of
mistakes in the calculating the price.
So, user is not happy. So, technically
it's successful but still failing the
task.
And as I mentioned, the unit test don't
save you here. And production is the
place when you learn what you need to uh
what you need to test on the first
place. All right. so what happens after
you launch the product, right? So you
need to monitor and you need to
understand and improve the system. Uh
and what's the source of the truth,
right? This is a log. Everyone has the
logs. Everyone loves the logs. You have
structured information.
And uh you know, those machines are the
best to understand and explore the logs
much better than any human, much faster,
taking rise and scripts to filter the
giant of walls. Um
And this is the most obvious way that
you can hand it to the agent. Uh
but as soon as you start working on
that, maybe you build an agent or skill
or whatever, you you quickly understand
this is not as easy as you imagine
because it needs a lot of reasoning. You
need to understand the problem to uh
differentiate if it's a real bug or a
noise, to deep dive into the fresh
trajectory, understand if it's a a
symptom or a root cause.
So actually, you'll find out that the
operate operating agent itself is an
agent problem.
So this is a look like end-to-end. So we
have a traces, you have trajectories,
you give the agent to access the code
base.
It diagnose the problem, understand what
is happening, and send the PR. And then
you can have a
skill or sub-agent or or whatever that
controls the PR uh because you know,
most of the agents are pretty eager to
send the PR. They love to fix the
problems. We prefer to have a separate
agent which has a like fresh context. It
try to check um
the PR on different angle, on different
view, run the um
the focus test.
And uh it is not biased of the problem
itself. It tries to criticize call the
PR. And uh sometimes it
uh requests the changes. Maybe it close
the PR directly and it helps us to to
filter those problems.
Uh and
uh
then you have the human in the loop,
sometimes you don't. Uh and we can talk
about this later. But, you know, this is
the most obvious thing that you can hand
it to the agent, which is which seems
like a pretty obvious for most of the
people.
And uh
a lot of teams use the same practice,
but I think people don't appreciate how
important it is, and you you need to
spend some time on that. You need to
calibrate. You need to make it reliable
to trust the loop. And this is the the
fastest loop that we ever had. So,
you know, after you build this simple uh
simple system,
you
uh already have the feeling and
understanding how behaves, what is
happening. You detect the problem, some
local fixes as soon as possible, and you
can have the PR in PR ready in half an
hour, and you can uh easily understand
what is happening. So, let me walk you
through uh how I'm handling this.
Everything is not optimal, but I think
this this will help you to to get some
point.
So, actually we have a two main flow.
The first one is the the fastest loop
that helps you to to detect and uh fix
the problems as soon as possible. And
the another one is like more on a zoom
out that
that helps you to have a on a high-level
understanding, and it helps you to have
hand on a pulse.
So, the first one is a log monitoring
agent, the one that I already mentioned.
So, you have trajectories, so we have
logs, we have the access to a code base,
and it runs every hour or uh
uh
every few 15 minutes, and it try to
understand the problem. It deep dives in
the in the logs, uh understand does the
user user end up stuck, and uh send the
PR, or sometimes send the Slack alert.
And this is this is pretty
uh important because sometimes the
problem is uh,
uh so critical so we need to
fix them as soon as possible and yeah,
it works pretty well.
So, this is the one example how the PR
can look like. So, you have a nice
description, a short explanation what is
happening, you have some metadata, you
have a nice diagrams, mermaid or ASCII
tables, maybe you will have some HTML
artifacts that helps you to
give you a glance of the problem and
quickly
understand what is this PR for.
So, this is the example how a static
analysis can look like. It helps you to
quickly give you a feedback, detect if
there are some critical problems.
Sometimes it it is just like heads-up or
you know, there are some warnings, there
are some problems so you need to check
them
when you have some time.
And as I mentioned the review agent is
uh, pretty critical because it tried to
check the problem in different angle. It
always tried to criticize the problem,
score the problem and
as soon as it's ready, it send the PR to
the human. And sometimes people talk
about that if we need to have a human in
the loop because you know, still human
in the bottleneck in this case.
In our case the the the the PR agent and
the review agent send 10 times more PR
than the three of us every day.
So, we need to have some clean system
how we're going to handle this
to not be a bottleneck in this system.
But from my experience as I mentioned
this PR and the review agent helps me to
have a nice description,
some artifacts that helps me to quickly
understand the problem
and maybe I spend a few minutes to at
least understand what is happening. So,
I think at this time it's okay but maybe
we'll remove it in the future.
And yeah, people are talking about that
so you need to you need you don't need
to be a person like in this problem.
Some of them prefer
to remove the humans in this loop.
But you know, the trend is that you need
to close the loop first. So, let's make
the problem
when you are the bottleneck and then you
can remove yourself pretty easily, I
think.
So, this is our some examples how the
review agent feedback can look like. As
you know, it requests some changes, you
have some summary, you have some
diagrams, explanation, what are them
some risks, some edge cases.
And sometimes
after a few iterations of the code in
the loop
where the key where the key is ready, so
we don't need you don't need to have any
more changes. So,
after that the human will
jump into the loop.
For the previous agent as I mentioned,
that is especially good when you want to
fix some local problems.
For our case, it runs every hour with
the chance on the one hour window of the
logs and
it doesn't have any
high-level understanding of the problem.
So, we found found out that we need to
have another system that helps us to to
get to get
like more than high-level explanation,
some kind of a health of the system. And
you know, visibility is the easiest
piece.
Before the agent, it was impossible, so
you cannot
deep dive or summarize some of the top
conversations. But right now, we can
have a system that helps you
to to score every conversations,
understand what's happening and give you
a high-level summary of the system.
So, this is the session analyzer and the
main goal is to just give me the score
of the health of the system, right? So,
we try to check every conversation, runs
a lot of state agents, it spend a lot of
tokens,
but yeah, it helps us to detect some
patterns connecting the dots and try to
understand some high-level patterns. And
yeah, it also detects some
like
logical problems, what is the cause,
how many tool calls did you use, how
many sub-agents, how many summary
happened or whatever. But also it gives
some AI insights, some entities, so you
have an understanding of the problem. So
right, as I mentioned, one of the main
problem is that you lose the control of
the user launch the production. So you
need to have the system that helps you
to control, at least to have some
understanding what is happening, how it
looks like, is healthy or what or not.
So
Actually, let me let me show you.
One of the example how how it looks
like. So actually we built it ourselves,
so there are a lot of other companies
and tools that provide the same kind of
system, but
I prefer to build it myself because I
know what I'm interested in for, what
I'm looking for. So as you can see, we
have the health of the system, we have
number of sessions that were analyzed,
the cost, we have the average score,
some success rate. We have some trends,
we have the AI insights, and this is the
most important part when the AI when the
agent try to connect the dots, find the
patterns. If there are some critical
ones, you have a description for each of
them, what is this, why it matters, what
are the root cause, how many sessions
affected, and some recommendation fix.
So right now this is just a anonymized
data, but it comes from a from a real
conversations.
So we have a score distribution,
each company
number of sessions or cost we have,
the sentiment analysis, some entities,
we have analytics about tool calls, all
the success rate, how many rejected and
why.
And you have a detailed analysis of the
each session. So, it ranks each one of
them, scores. It is
how many times it was running, how many
messages, how many tool calls,
how many summary, and you have a
detailed explanation for each of them,
what was the problem. It is something
that you need attention, and believe it
helps a lot, and it helps you to
check and watch across hundreds of
uh conversations. So, the main goal of
this dashboard and the system is not to
fix some
uh
um
specific problems or bug. This is more
than a high-level that helps you to
watch across hundreds or thousands of
real conversations. So, you can run it
once in a week, two times in a week, or
something like that.
All right. So, the next one is that
mm So, the problem of the previous uh
agent that I mentioned is like the first
one helps you to detect the specific
problem. The second one is to give you a
high-level understanding, but both of
them works from a angle of the logs or a
uh code or a session itself, but you
need to have some kind of user
perspective, right? So, that's why we
have some computer use agent that helps
you to
uh to open the browser,
uh to log in, and try to simulate the
customer itself, because sometimes you
have some problems in the UI. You need
to um
check if everything looks good.
Uh and uh yeah, sometimes code and logs
cannot help you uh in this way.
So, this is uh example how it looks
like. So, you used Codex uh sometimes.
So, it used um
uh the browser itself.
Uh
Actually, this is pretty slow.
Uh and we try to build a specific skill
that know our uh website, our DOM, how
it looks like, and that is much faster,
and it can open the website, login, open
the sessions, send the messages, check
what is happening.
Uh, and also check, how it looks like,
what what are the some artifacts. And,
yeah, it was pretty good. But, yeah, you
you you need to know that it it it will
spend a lot of a lot of tokens.
And also,
for all of those problems, you need to
remember that,
you need to give access to all the kind
of tools that is needed. So, you need to
have a lot of trajectories and metrics,
database, UI,
so as the humans need, right? So, you
need to give all context, all
possibilities to understand what is
happening. For example, for the computer
use agent, when detect some problems, it
should be able to
analyze the trajectories, check the
database, to understand what happened.
And, you know, that's why I'm calling it
a meta harness, the whole system, when
everything is connected, and the PR or
the answer from the agents are depend on
the depend on the real problem, and
they're not casing what is happening.
So, the most is not the model alone, and
you need to build the agent, or a
system, or a harness around it,
which which watches itself, understand,
improve, and help you at least to at
least to monitor what is happening, but
also in the ideal case, to close the
loop, send automatic PR, notifications,
whatever, and help you to speed up the
process.
So, shipping is the easiest part today.
If you want to if you want to build a
production agent, you need to close the
loop first, because somehow people are
not talking about how important it is
what happens after you launch, so
everyone can have the same model,
everyone can have the same agent or
harness, but you need to have some
internal system that helps you in this
process,
detect the problems,
and give you sense what is happening,
and helps to make the product better.
Thank you.